foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 3992
object class safe
special containment procedures all
instances of scp-3992 are to be kept in
a standard containment Locker at site
17.
description
scp-3992 is a number of children's
Halloween face masks instances come in a
range of designs portraying various
Halloween themed monsters instances are
constructed out of simple plastic
materials paint and string each instance
Bears a label reading Dr wondertainment
wacky Halloween fun masks on the
interior
scp-3992 instances do not display any
anomalous properties when worn by a
non-anomalous individual however when
worn by an anomalous entity it will
appear to physically change into an
adolescent humanoid of varying
appearance any clothing worn by the
wearer will appear to change into a
costume fitting the scp-3992 instance's
appearance clothing will simply appear
to manifest on entities not wearing
anything
to clarify anomalous entities who wear
an instance of scp-3992 do not actually
experience a physical change in
appearance but rather appear to become
humanoid changes in an entity's
appearance and manifestic clothing
cannot be physically felt and affected
entities may continue to function and
interact with their surroundings as
normal this effect will cease when the
scp-3992 instance is removed the
physical appearance gained by wearers of
scp-3992 instances differ significantly
in bodily features including skin tone
skin color size and gender
Discovery log
scp-3992 was discovered on 24 20 in a
house in Wisconsin United States the
house had been seized by the foundation
Under Suspicion of anomalous activity
originating from it among scp-3992
several other anomalous items were found
a majority of which were wondertainment
origin the previous residents of the
house were found to have fled the area
and remain unfound
scp-3992 was located in a cardboard box
in The house's attic among several
Halloween decorations as of note the
name Stanley was found written on the
inside of
scp-3992-6 vampire mask records show a
child by the same name to have been one
of The house's previous residents
the following document was found along
with scp-3992
we at Dr wondertainment would like to
give you a very special gift in
accordance with the holidays for your
continued loyalty over the years we
would like to present you a very special
treat to those of you who might find it
rather difficult to fit in we at Dr
Wonder Damon believe in embracing what
others might consider strange and spooky
there are too many wonders in this world
Locked Away by those who just don't
understand or find the abnormal too
scary we know firsthand that it can be
Troublesome accepting who you are
especially in the world of the mundane
so we've come with wonderful news that
for just one night you may go out and
celebrate the strange and the scary
without worry of what others may think
of you for our customers out there who
struggle with these feelings on a daily
basis we have decided to give you a
special free of charge reward this
Halloween a little something to show our
grad attitude for your continued support
in this box you will find a complete set
of our new wondertainment wacky
Halloween fun masks
celebrate this Halloween with a costume
so amazingly convincing you won't even
be able to recognize yourself have fun
out there kids try not to wander into
any Dark Forest while trick-or-treating
and if you run into a headless fellow
along the way give him a good hello from
us to Dr wondertainment
we miss you a lot old friend we hope
you're being taken good care of from Dr
wondertainment
[Music]
addendum 3992 1. testing of scp-3992 on
several other SCP objects was suggested
as a means of discovering the range of
its effects when used on anomalous
entities of varying physical nature
approval of various SCP objects for
testing was authorized
testing log
test 3992 102.
subject
scp-2006 taking the form of the Creature
from the haunted sea
scp-3992 instance
scp-3992-1 werewolf mask
results
scp-2006 appeared as an adolescent male
humanoid wearing a torn plaid shirt and
jeans a pair of rubber gloves resembling
clawed hands with gray fur appeared on
scp-2006's hands
notes scp-2006 was asked to change its
physical appearance during the test in
order to see how the effects of scp-3992
would react to scp-2006's shape-changing
abilities several changes to
scp-2006's size skin tone and hair
occurred but remained humanoid
scp-2006 initially refused to remove
scp-3992-1 at first but eventually
complied once researchers assured it
that it was nowhere near as scary as the
previous form
test 3992-201
subject scp-2662
scp-3992 instance
scp-3992 2 which mask
results
scp-2662 took the form of an adolescent
female
scp-2662 appeared dressed in a black
spider web-themed witch costume complete
with a pointed witch hat holding a
broomstick which disappeared along with
the perceived effects of
scp-3992-2 when removed to node is
scp-2662's appearance as a female rather
than a male this is believed to have
occurred due to
scp-3992-2 resembling a generic female
witch
notes
scp-2662 commented on the whole physical
change to be rather uncomfortable
scp-2662 later assured that what it had
stated previously was not meant in any
way to come off as disrespectful or
insensitive stating it had nothing
against females and that they could be
cultists if they desired
test 3992 301
subject scp-1279-1
scp-3992 instance
scp-3992-3 Frankenstein's monster mask
results instance of
scp-1279-1 appeared as a human male
covered in green body paint wearing a
Frankenstein's monster costume
consisting of a black shirt and pants
torn gray coat and boots with a pair of
metal bolts protruding from its neck
instance appeared standing upright on
its perceived legs
upon removal of scp-1279 from the
instance
scp-3992-3's effects ceased
notes interesting
scp-3992 must perceive 1279.1 as
anomalous as long as it wears 1279. this
may be the case when testing with other
similar anomalies
test 3992-404
subject scp-2980-1
scp-3992 instance
scp-3992-4 Devil's Mask
results
scp-2981's physical age did not change
all abnormal features and body parts of
scp-2981 appeared to be replaced with
pieces of costume clothing including a
fake red tail and a pair of boots
resembling cloven feet
scp-2981 took the form of a human male
of unknown race coated in red body paint
notes
scp-2981 commented on the effects of
scp-3992-4 to be rather humorous but was
nothing compared to the real thing
scp-2981 later claimed to recognize the
name wondertainment when questioned
scp-2981 stated that the name baired a
striking resemblance to that of a
cousins three times removed
scp-2981 did not give any other useful
information
test 3992 503
subject scp-2287
scp-3992 instance
scp-3992 5 mummy mask
results
scp-2287 appeared no longer headless
scp-2287 appeared as a bald human male a
pair of green pupils were visible
through
scp-3992-5's eye holes inspections
showed its Mister tattoo to no longer be
present no physical changes were present
in the rest of
scp-2287's body as it had no other
physical abnormalities
scp-2287's clothing was replaced by
layers of yellow tinted linen cloth
wrapped around its entire body similar
to an Egyptian mummy
notes of significant node
scp-2287's anomalous properties ceased
functioning while wearing
scp-3992-5 whether this is due to it
being a wondertainment product is
unknown
scp-2287 commented on finding the mask
fun to wear saying that it was nice to
see what it was like from the other end
scp-2287 later asked if it were possible
to wear
scp-3992-5 again at some point
decision currently pending the effects
of scp-3992 may prove useful for the
containment of
scp-2287's anomalous properties
test 3992-609
subject 956.
scp-3992 instance
scp-3992-6 vampire mask
results
scp-956 appeared as an adolescent
Caucasian female with long pink hair
costume consisted of a black cape and
pants and red velvet waistcoat
notes scp-956 initially showed no signs
of bodily movement remaining in its
passive State however after several
seconds
scp-956 visibly looked down at itself
and began heavily wretching
scp-956 attempted to remove
scp-3992-6 with its perceived hands when
this failed scp-956 began clawing at
scp-3992-6 violently until it was
removed by an assisting d-class
addendo 3992 2.
on
2909-20 a package was found outside of
site 17 addressed to the foundation
inside were a second set of scp-3992
instances consisted of a skeleton
jack-o'-lantern Banshee zombie and clown
the following note was included
to the SCP Foundation we see that you've
been playing around with our product and
the proof of it greatly it's nice to see
you giving others a taste of the
holidays and we hope you're having fun
within yourselves as a sign of gratitude
for your vigorous testing of so many of
our products we present to you the
newest batch of wondertainment wacky
Halloween fun mask
the following set has not been
officially released just yet but we're
hoping to get them out soon enough we
hope you'll share these with a few more
of your guests and get some top-notch
results with all honesty though we make
these products because many don't get
the chance to experience proper
childhood or even celebrate such a
unique time of year so during that
magical time when the mundane blend with
the uncanny we want to celebrate it
right
give a little more
because that's what it's all about right
yours Dr wondertainment
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Dr fellerin
silent
tomothy
zargaron
Professor Puffer
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J tilp
well remember
vinyl
gavios the hollow
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crap guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
and NJ vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you